There may be cases where you want a
notification to only appear on a phone,
and you don't want it to be synchronized
over to your wearable devices.
An example might be a notification
showing that there is an upload in
progress on the phone.
But it's not a notification that a user
needs to be notified on their wearable.
The NotificationCompat.Builder class
contains a method called setLocalOnly.
You can use this to insure
notifications only appear on the phone.
If you want to make a notification
that only appears on a wearable and
not the phone, you'll need to
wait until the next lesson
to learn more about how to do this.